bien je suis arrivé en L elle m'a
chauffé direct jure ouais elle m'a dit
bah oui elle m'a dit que pendant les
pubs elle aimerait bien sucer je vous
jure je vous jure que c'est vrai je vous
jure que c'est vrai c'est vrai ou pas
Dani j'ai dit que je je de temps en
temps je prononcais ce mot pendant les
pubs il faudrait qu'il regarde parce
qu'il y a des réactions non j'ai pas
Ricola ah ben oui j'arrête pas de sucer
mais ça se voit pas parce que je les
prends toutes petites en fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Lesire
a il a plus rien à faire quand même dans
les
couloirs mais il faut qu'elle ait
quelqu'un faut qu'on trouve quelqu'un
mais là je je me sens soulagé là parce
que depuis tout à l'heure elle essaie de
mettre la main et
tout ça va toi g moi non elle me fait
rien tu as changé de coiffure ouais un
peu aérien le vendredi rev bien ce que
tu faisais
avant est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
beaucoup de chroniqueurs font des vannes
pourres pendant l'émission bah parce que
c'est leur seul van alors et ça et aussi
parce qu'ils se motiv entre eux ils se
félicit c'est exemple avec Jean Michel
c'est le bon camarade de la semaine car
c'est un bon camarade et nul ne peut le
nier la ville de zur a décidé de faire
une drôle de recommandation à tous les
parents de la ville elle conseille
désormais d'arrêter d'employer les mots
papa et maman dire écoute moi d'abord je
suis ravi de pas d'être allemand déjà ça
c'est
c'estisse bra bravo ah il est bon il est
beau
encore une
[Applaudissements]
connerieou là c'est Sacha là c'est
[Rires]
Michel
bon là c'est sachelle base là c'est
Michel nous sommes
[Musique]
lundi vous étiez je cro c'était mardi
vous allez pas me casser les
couilles donc nous sommes lundi vous
êtes en fête religieuse puisque c'était
qui pour alors quiip pour pour ceux qui
le savent pas c'est une fête Michel
Marie mich Mar je peux le faireich
oui alors il est
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
19h34 on l'adore
onore
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors il était 20h34 peut-être
[Rires]
35 comment tu veux qu'on l'accueille
après est on sait que lundi on est
mort c'est on est mort sa pas limite
maintenant il est 20h50 on parle de fait
diviv truc sérieux quoi oui alors c il
est 20h34 lorsque cyil entre dans la
pièce il se déshabille se dévêu avec son
avec ses doigts Gill selon alors selon
certaines sources non c'est qui jeis
vous expliquer
[Rires]
pourquoi ilend laule il va falloir vous
confier Cyril parce que je sais pas ce
qui s'est passé à la synagogue il y a
quelques années anné ou avant 2018 avant
2017 puisque vous avez été traumatisé
par l'hygiène bucodentaire de quelqu'un
puisque c'est devenu un toc chez vous
vous êtes le traumatisé de la
semaine tous les gars à la
synagogue veulent te
parler sauf que c'est plus une une
synagogue c'est un magasin de cuire mon
frère je connais les gars ils viennent
de parler frère ils ont une haline mon
frère on dirait qu'ils ont du cuire dans
la bouche à 17h à la C
je peux vous dire on a l'impression
d'être dans un magasin de cuir en
Turquie quand tu manges pas pendant
qu'il à partir de 14h30 tu as comme une
savat dans la bouche à partir d'un
moment de la journée frère comme si tu
avais une babouche dans la
bouche il y a toujours des Clum qui
veulent te parler mais c'est quoi le
problème avec les gens qui viennent vous
parler Cyr maisah il plus de la laine et
vous n'aimez pas ça Cyril pas du tout
vous êtes en boucle et tous les gars
veulent te dire des
secrets c'est insupportable et les mecs
qui veulent te raconter leur vie ils
veulent aller contre le covid ils
veulent enlever le masque
et là frère le mec te parle sans rigol
je voyais parfois il des animaux
qui il y a toujours des C qui veulent te
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parlertis faut se boner les enfin avant
de repartir cy sa que c'est une émission
un peu à part dans le PAF il se passe
des choses qu'on ne voit pas ailleurs et
du coup j'ai voulu voir ce qui se
faisait un peu sur les autres chaînes à
la même heure c'est le retour d'une
séquence que vous adorez c'est le
pendant ce tempsl sur les autres
chaînes
[Musique]
bonjour à tout le monde dans le monde
anglosaxon ce fut la bombe de la semaine
écoulée là ça
délire attendez je kiffe protter mon h
en
[Musique]
fait à T
sur et bien sûr on va jouer ce soir à
qui veut frter
son l'arrivée des caméras spy point pour
le chasseur de chevreuil c'est une vraie
bénédiction comme ceci vas Frot ton h
vas-y frottetoi là mais tu vas le casser
quel mot désigne à la fois un jeune
rameau de vigne ditien s ça ah
oui voilà
voilà
voilà romain romain romain tu es le
grand
gagnant c'est pas
par quelle heure il il est 19h34 il est
19h34 oui Cyril c'est problématique
puisque selon certaines sources alors ça
reste à
confirmer Gill verdè serait entré avec
une chevelure
problématique il n'avait pas mis de gel
et c'est à partir de là que tout bascule
l'affaire est grave
Cyril Gill entre dans la pièce il est
vêtu d'une veste
grise et c'est là que tout
dérapes c'est le chat dans la gorge
oui c'est là où tu es le meilleur c'est
là où es le
[Applaudissements]
meilleur me dire un truc
ouie cette veste oui pourquoi bah au cas
où tu tombes en
panne je vous laisse sur
ça
allez alors les Chéries on va parler des
infos du jour parce qu'il y a pas mal
d'infos euh dans un instant vous avez vu
ce qu' a dit Michel Sardou très fort
hein il y a un collégien victime du
nouveau jeu le jeu de la virgule on vous
dira ce que c'est le jeu de la virgule
et euh sa vie loin des médias c'est
début son enfance le meilleur ami John
ja Goldman livre tous ses secrets ça
c'est très important au moment de la
sorti de l'affaire Goldman vous avez
compris leoui oui bien sûr le film parce
que qui est Goldman le film c'est le
frère le filmà Pierre Goldman oui mais
c'est le frère oui Pierre Goldman
Jean-Jacques Goldman voilà le frère et
le film est sorti mercredi oui mais le
frère c'est le frère oui c'est le frère
le film frère du film c'est le frère du
film dans le film Le
Frère à tout de
suite